jury deliberations have begun in the
trial of 18 year old kyle rittenhouse in
kenosha wisconsin rittenhouse faces a
range of charges for fatally shooting
two people during protests last august
and wounding a third the case involves
the flashpoints of gun rights racial
justice demonstrations and law and order
so let's head now to kenosha for some on
the ground reporting with bloomberg
news's skylar woodhouse skyler so good
to see you can you just tell us what the
atmosphere was like overall when you
were around the courthouse in downtown
it was it thick with tension
yes so when you're at the courthouse and
you're on the stairs leading up to the
courthouse there there's a lot of
tension there's a lot of people on both
sides some supporting kyle some who are
not um and you know there's a lot of
tension among the the two sides of the
story but if you drive a few minutes
away from the courthouse it's very calm
there's a different side of kenosha but
you know given the trial and how
everything is centered at the courthouse
there is truly attention surrounding the
courthouse but it's kind of strange how
if you go just a few minutes down the
road it's almost like it's very quiet
and calm and you might not even know
that there's this trial happening yeah
like almost a different world entirely
now we know that two men were killed and
a third was injured just recount for us
again the facts of the case here what is
kyle rittenhouse accused of doing
yes so what we know is you know that he
he drove across state lines
after the after when um jacob blate was
um shot um by a police officer jacob
blake was an unarmed black man um so
kyle drove across state lines from
illinois with his mom um and he you know
he came to the protests that were
happening here in kenosha
he
had a he had he had a weapon and he was
you know when he shot the three men he
said that he
was acting in self-defense so that's
what we know and you know the jury i
mean the prosecutors the defense
attorneys they've been they've been
going at it um and now they're in jury
deliberations and just to wait and see
what happens yeah and we just detailed
the five individual felony charges that
kyle rittenhouse faces um the most
severe one is first degree intentional
homicide which in some states would be
equivalent to first-degree murder
it's really among the most serious
charges and if convicted he could face
life in prison what's interesting is
that earlier this week the judge
dismissed a sixth charge against
rittenhouse which was possessing a
dangerous weapon as a minor because he
was 17 when the shootings happened and
he's now 18 years old so he's a legal
adult now wisconsin is an open carry
state so he was not doing anything wrong
by being armed in the state i'm just
curious when you were
at the courthouse with all the tension
there i mean
were there people talking about carrying
guns near the courthouse did you see
anyone carrying weapons
aside from the you know the officers who
are here at the courthouse i personally
have not
seen anyone um carrying a weapon i
haven't really heard any or i haven't
heard any language where you know some
of the protesters might be you know
saying oh they're gonna you know bring a
weapon or that someone they know is
going to bring a weapon i haven't heard
anything of that nature there's been
more just um
a really rowdy sense of dialect among
the two sides of the story where they're
verbally really going after one another
yeah almost like they're they're having
the argument with each other um
in a trial but not really because
they're outside i it's this has been
playing out for two weeks now and it
seems to really come down to whether he
was acting in self-defense or not or
whether he was committing serious crimes
what are people saying specifically i
know that you went around and talked
with a lot of different people to gather
their thoughts what did you learn
yeah so i've spoken to a ton of people
some people you know they're really
passionate and they firmly believe you
know that you know kyle is acting in
self-defense others feel that that was
not the case um so take a listen to some
of the people that i spoke with
so you were here when everything first
happened so what inspired you to come
back
um to show support for kyle i was in
that situation and the actual rifle was
in self-defense so i'm staying with the
support of him and what has the energy
been like today energy well you know you
got people here who have no real purpose
for being here but starting a problem a
guy over there with a dog just came to
bullhorn and screamed in my ear in front
of the police officers
security right there standing by waiting
to arrest me and what would you like to
see happen
i would like for kyle not to have any
charges
because he did not he acted in
self-defense he did nothing
the whole community of kenosha was in
uh despair that night there is
replaceable damage that occurred rioters
not peaceful protesters how do you think
everything is going i mean what do you
think is going on it's iffy right now we
don't know what the verdict is going to
be if the verdict is going to be not
guilty or a mistrial or anything in that
type of nature
we pray for the community not to do no
harm to their community of kenosha
so as you just heard there you know
there was a lot of background noise
happening as i was speaking to those
people and you know a lot of people are
just there to
to make their opinion known to make
where they stand known so you know
they're using their voice for whatever
side that they're
um on and they're just trying to
really just make sure that some other
person hears their side of the story or
hears their opinion and people that i've
spoken with you know so yesterday on
monday i've been here since sunday night
and on monday there weren't as many
people here there's still not a large
large group of people here
like we have seen in past protests but
you know there's a few more people here
today
so the security presences
they've the officers have come more
outside of the courthouse and yesterday
they were they kind of remained more
inside but they've taken more of an
outside approach today um i think with
just you know a few more people and
today people are definitely more verbal
than they were yesterday so we'll see
how things go for the rest of the week
until we get that decision yeah which
makes sense given that the jury
deliberations began today and it's still
not clear how long this process will
take before verdict does come along you
know the shooting would not have
happened if it were not for kyle
rittenhouse and other people
volunteering to
come over and protect local businesses
during the protests in kenosha i'm just
wondering of the people that you saw
there was someone who said that they
were there to support kyle rittenhouse
were there any volunteers who
said that they were there actively to
protect small businesses in case
anything does happen
i have not spoken with anyone who has
said that they've been there to you know
say like i'm here to protect the people
of kenosha connects protect small
businesses um you know i think as the
week goes on we you know there might be
someone who who comes and you know who
says that i think we are starting to see
more people kind of trickle in and to
kenosha as the week goes on one thing
that i found interesting is you know
people are taking off of work to come
here and be involved in the protest so
whichever side they're they're
they're on and so you know we might see
that going forward but it's just a
matter of wait and see yeah yeah what
also is really interesting to me is just
how much everyone is talking about this
trial um you mentioned that it feels
like a different world a couple blocks
away from the courthouse but here in new
york it's of course a big topic of
conversation i was looking on twitter
and bill ackman the hedge fund
billionaire has been tweeting about this
he was tweeting that he was watching the
trial and he felt that kyle rittenhouse
was telling the truth and acting in
self-defense his main point though was
that rittenhouse's life is at risk
justice demands a fair trial he says
society would benefit greatly if
politics did not enter the courtroom and
convict innocent people so he's trying
to separate the trial from
political tribes political bias are you
hearing a lot of people talk about
conservatives versus progressives when
you talk to them uh near the courthouse
yeah so you know there are some
signs that are like black lives matter
there is some sort of rhetoric around
that but i think what people here are
trying to also say is that this isn't
necessarily about black lives matter
it's more so about well you know
a white man who was armed
get away
with what he did and if it was a black
man in his situation there might be a
different story so i think that's also
kind of the story that some of these
protesters are trying to to say to the
other side um is that kind is that
conversation right there which is
i think where a lot of the the
discussion comes in among the two sides
of the story when it gets kind of down
to that racial component gotcha gotcha
and one of the folks you talked to
referenced how their riots and and you
haven't seen that happen yet so far
things have been pretty peaceful but i
just wonder do we know how the
authorities in kenosha are preparing uh
for when there is a verdict if there is
any kind of unrest i mean do they have
people standing by
yes so there's definitely like there is
a security presence um you know you'll
see some you know patrol cars around
there's signs saying you can't park here
don't park there um what we do know is
you know the national guard is on
standby um you know if things were to
escalate and really take it take a
different turn you know they might be
called in um so that's really all we
have from a security standpoint and
again it's just really i think more
decisions will be made as time goes on
if the crowd
grows yeah and and as you mentioned more
people are taking time off they're
making their way over to kenosha does
anyone have a sense or is anyone
speculating on when a verdict would come
through
based on previous trials does anyone
have a sense of how long this will go on
for
you know i think it's kind of like
everyone knows it could happen
sooner than later it could happen you
know whenever it could happen right now
for all i know you know i think there's
just kind of this wait and see situation
where people are just kind of waiting
for that notification that you know
they've reached a decision and
and
which
we're really just going to wait and see
what happens all right bloomberg news is
schuyler woodhouse thank you so much
skyler is reporting on the ground in
kenosha wisconsin she's been there for
the last couple days and we'll be
checking in with her for more updates